who do you think is the best comedian of
all time
oh that's a great question greatest of
you mentioned carlin your uncle's liking
carlin
well carlin is great carlin is
really hard to argue with but
chappelle is also really great um
louis c.k is really great i don't know
that there's what joan rivers
is great i don't know you smile at that
beast of a comic i'm not aware of her
stand up actually just of a comic ask
rogue and ask any of them
um kennison's great so what makes a
great comic do you think
in the history of comedy just like i
said something
at the moment in a way
found a way to communicate with people
in the funniest possible way
at that moment and illustrate you know
illustrated larger truths about
life in what they did and i think that
guys like louie and chappelle
and uh pryor and kinnison and hicks
people like joan rivers uh have done
that and even you know modern people
people
like maria bamford's an amazing comedian
it's just a different style of
comedy per se but she's an amazing
community uh you know
kat williams is an amazing comedian you
know he really is
does he have any well see the one of the
things you kind of mentioned the
community as you mentioned they were
kind of fearless and saying the
difficult things that needs to be said
cal williams is more i actually i don't
remember his comedy but i think it's
just more
wild out there well to an extent but you
can watch it he's got stuff he talks
about
stuff he talks about race brilliantly he
talks about america brilliantly no i
think there's a lot of stuff there
and of course chris rock chris rock of
course it's so hard you can't really
pick one
you just gotta there's a class of people
that throughout this
history of this business which is not
that long of a history it's you know
pretty much within the last century
uh you know that are have been really
influential sometimes it's style the way
they deliver things sometimes it's
substance of how they
you know what they're saying or
sometimes it's just a style of what
they're saying i mean and we're only
talking about stand-up comedians right
so there's a million great comedians i
mean if we're going to talk about jim
carrey
and adam sandler and chris farley i mean
these are brilliant
and those guys are bigger influences on
comedy i think than stand-ups really
truly
so there's there's there's so many
brilliant people in the in the business
who was for you and like influential
just the early on his was influential
because i'd watch bill hicks and i'd be
like this guy's saying crazy [ __ ] on
stage and this is the only way he can
get away with it is because it's so
funny and he was calling out like you
know the military-industrial complex and
and he was talking about the first gulf
war i remember he said a joke
that i heard it made me sit up straight
he goes he goes he was in canada and he
said we got a war in the states he was
talking about the first gulf war
and he said i was in the unenviable
position of being for the war but
against the troops
and to me i loved that joke it was so
funny to me and i was like oh you can't
get away with that anywhere
other than standing on a stage you
couldn't ever say that in an office
really and this was before like it was
like pc
and they said the other thing i always
knew that comedians
had to say [ __ ] and have it be funny
enough that you couldn't get away with
it in polite society that was the whole
point
that was why it was a dark theater or
dark nightclub that's when people had a
few drinks that's what the art form was
and that's why
i so a guy like that was influential
because i started watching him
and then of course like you know i loved
snl when i was a kid and i would watch
chris farley and i would watch
um you know people like even john
belushi going back in the day but i'd
watch adam sandler
and will farrell and all these guys i
mean the there's so many funny people
but
bill hicks was kind of funny and then
patrice o'neill was like probably my
favorite comedian who's made me laugh
more than anybody
else um i think it was you actually that
uh maybe on your podcast we're talking
about patrice onyeon that
he was actually vicious to others
i think he was a little mean to other
people but he was very good to people
he liked i guess i think he was like not
i mean he wasn't
and i've never met him i have no insight
info but from what i've heard he was
like
no nonsense guy right he just said what
he wanted to say
but i think in terms of comedians i
don't know of anyone funnier than
patrice o'neill
who said in modern times that said more
about our society than him i mean he was
just a brilliantly funny guy
on the radio he was funny on his
specials he was funny
everywhere he was funny and there's
something else to be said about
the whole medium of comedians doing
podcasts yeah cause that's a
it unlocks a weird special new thing
that changed everything i mean rogan
started with that
yeah you're doing that it i think that's
a
whole other form of like standups yeah
the ones that have a lot to say almost
like
uh we get to witness the process of the
creation of the jokes in a way or the
mind
right the sort of the evolution of the
mind behind the jokes
which is comedians relate to social
media
comedians are committed comedy's uh
it's a performance-based medium so it's
about getting up and doing it getting up
in a club getting up in the theater
getting up in a bar getting up wherever
you can get up
and comedy for years was about
performance
and then on the higher end it was about
movies and tv shows
but we were very slow to get on youtube
we're very slow to adapt to technology
we're very slow to monetize anything we
did on the internet
so podcasting was a way for comics and
funny people
to kind of get into that space start
earning money
and now because the pandemic has really
become essential
and it helps you and even without the
pandemic it was where people
were it was how you were building a fan
base and that's like
you know but comics were very reticent
to embrace social media at all because
they thought it was cheap
and they didn't like it and they thought
the people on it were idiots and were
unfunny and it was just a blatant
you know whatever it was whether it was
a money grab or it was just too
commercial and
in in a sense where they're like hey
look at me like it was just goofy right
um and then comics i think got
displaced because all the youtubers came
in
and all the social media stars came in
and they really knocked
comics off because now people are much
more like if you ask anyone under 30 who
their favorite
favorite comedian is they say david
dobrik and there's nothing wrong with
that david's a funny guy but like
what you you know i'm not especially to
me
a ton but that's okay i don't you know
but he makes people laugh so he's funny
um but he's what people you know that's
a comedian now
so comics got beat by other people
coming into a digital space
before they did laying the groundwork
and
taking it over and now comics are just
trying to stay alive
like even my podcast which is people
really like it thank god and i love
doing it
the tim dillon show well thank you uh
i was late you know i mean i was i just
you know it i've been podcasting for a
long time but really dedicating myself
and putting the resources behind it i
was late to it like i was like hey i'm
i'm telling jokes on stage which is
great but i should have been allocating
more time to building an infrastructure
online
and i wasn't doing it and a lot of
comments weren't doing it funny comics
weren't doing
comics that should be doing it and i
think when the pandemic ends a lot of
comics will just keep doing
live stand up but i will keep obviously
i'm going to go back on the road and do
live standing but i will keep doing this
podcast and building digitally
but you're also exploring ideas you're
doing like short videos
yes and so on you're you're trying to
look for different
mediums of uh
everywhere i want to be funny everywhere
i love making things too my producer ben
avery
is like a brilliant editor and comedic
mind even though he's not a
stand-up he's able to on he understands
funny he understands what makes me funny
we're able to make
these really i mean some of those videos
they're just brilliant little videos
even though they're tiny little videos
they're [ __ ] as funny as anything
and it's not me it's me working with
somebody else to make something really
great
and if and and it's that relationship
that's very important
well um in some sense the uh the medium
of a short video
is a challenge just like the medium of a
short tweet of course
how to say something i mean whatever the
flavor is
uh of what's in your heart what's your
mind
how to say it whether it's the goal is
funny right or something
or just uh and express an idea i think
it's the whole thing that's important
to us is that it's an extension of
really like an extension of your
friendship in a way like are you guys
laughing at it right are you guys making
each other laugh
about this idea yeah and if that's the
case other people are going to laugh at
it
you know i think so much of the old
medium was like everything was top down
okay pitch me this idea i pitch it to
the showrunner they pitch it to the
network they pitch to this
that the you know standards and
practices sales and
we got to go through everything now it's
just like our me and a few buddies or
even just one buddy
laughing at this idea does it captivate
us
and do we see it visually and also
a great line from roseanne a guy
not roseanne but a guy that worked on
roseanne uh the old roseanne the great
one he said
is it funny with the sound off right
that's what we try to do that's
brilliant
is it funny with the sound off when you
see me and the dumb things or me and the
mega mccain
or me and the thing is it funny with the
sound off and if you're funny with the
sound off you have a good starting point
that's hilarious because uh you
i would say you're one of the people
because most people are not
funny with this honor most comedians
like you you will farrell is another
example of that
there's something about when i click on
one of your videos
it's funny just like the first thing i
see yeah just your face
well thank you that's very sweet but i
mean i mean thank god i mean that's what
we try to do right we're trying to be
funny yeah
you